-Our next guest is
a supermodel, actress,
"New York Times" best-selling
author you know from films
such as "Gone Girl"
and "I Feel Pretty."
New episodes of her podcast
"High Low with EmRata" drop
every Tuesday and Thursday
across all podcast platforms.
Please welcome back to the show
Emily Ratajkowski, everyone.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back.
-Thank you.
-I am so happy to have you here.
Last time you were here,
we talked a little bit about
your son.
He's coming up on 2 years.
-Yep.
-We just had Halloween. Did you
have an enjoyable Halloween?
-I did.
It was the first Halloween he
really got what was going on.
Last year he was like,
"Ah, whatever."
So I dressed him up with my dog.
-I really appreciate a dog and
kid costume that has this --
-Okay, thank you so much.
-That just ties together
like this.
-It honestly -- It came together
very quickly.
-Yeah.
[ Audience aws ]
That is just an excellent,
excellent Little Red Riding Hood
and Big Bad Wolf situation
right there.
-Thank you so much.
My son was not convinced of
the cape until he saw --
His first word is dog, but he
says "doggin" for every dog.
So when he saw "doggin" in the
hat, he was, like, ready to go.
-Gotcha.
-And then we hit the streets.
-And now, who got more attention
on the streets?
The baby or the dog?
-So we were on a stoop in the
West Village with four babies,
like all adorably dressed.
And this man was sitting at the
top of the steps, and it was
like I wasn't there,
the babies weren't there,
it was just all about Columbo.
-I think if you can get a dog
in a bonnet,
people have a real appreciation.
-He had an emotional journey,
though.
-Yeah. Oh, interesting.
-First he felt proud.
He was loving it.
Then he had shame.
[ Laughter ]
Like, the bonnet was --
We had a whole thing.
We were there for an hour,
and people were like zooming in
on him.
It was amazing.
-I like the idea that you think
there was a moment where your
dog transferred into shame.
-I will show you the pictures.
-"What am I doing?"
-No, he was like,
"I'm really into it.
I'm really into it."
He understood, like,
"I'm the big brother.
I have to be committed to this."
Like, "it's putting our little
baby in the mood."
I swear to God.
I don't know if y'all have dogs,
but like it's real.
And then all of a sudden, he
just laid down and was like...
[ Audience aws ]
...and had a little existential
crisis, but it's okay.
We made it through, and we won't
do it again, you know.
-And still, you got
a perfect picture,
and that's all that matters.
-Thank you.
-Have you seen your son develop
a sense of humor?
Do you feel like that's --
-Yes.
-This is around the age
that happens.
-Yes. He loves to be,
like, thrown around.
-Okay.
-That sounds questionable.
-So he's like
a physical comedian.
-Yes, he's very physical.
Definitely loves when I make
funny faces, put on glasses,
all of that.
But, like, he loves to just
get thrown on the bed.
And then, if you put a pillow
on him, he just giggles,
like laughs underneath
the pillow
and just wants you to drop it
on him multiple times.
-Yeah.
-So I do it.
-I oblige.
-Look, you're a people pleaser,
you know.
-Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
-If he finds something he likes,
you got to stick with it.
-No, and also, making your kid
laugh, there's nothing better.
-It's the best thing
in the world.
Nothing's more heartbreaking
than how much funnier
my kids think my wife is
than me.
[ Laughter ]
Breathtaking, 'cause
in real life, it ain't close.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know.
Are you sure?
-I'm not sure anymore.
-I mean, I dunno,
maybe your wife --
-I have a lot of self-doubt.
-Yeah.
-I want to ask -- We talked --
You did --
You wrote a book of essays.
Now you have a podcast.
Did writing the essays
in any way
inform the choice to do
a podcast?
Did you always think it was
something you wanted to do?
-Totally. Last time I was here,
I was talking about my book.
Thanks for having me again.
-Of course.
-Yeah, I -- you know, people --
Every celebrity, like, gets
approached to do a podcast.
And I was like, "I don't want to
be one of those people."
And I was working on the book,
and I just really wanted to
finish it so that there was
a POV and people could have
an understanding of, like, who I
am before I started the podcast.
But it's perfect for me.
I love writing essays,
and I love making TikToks.
And a podcast is right
in the middle.
-Yeah.
-So it's perfect.
I'm really, really enjoying it.
It's actually 2 episodes a week,
so it's 96 episodes a year.
It's a lot of work,
but I love it.
-It's more work
than people think.
-It's so much work.
But I'm really enjoying it.
I'm actually getting a taste for
what you do a bit.
-The interviewing side of it?
-The interviewing, yeah.
One episode is an interview,
and one episode is
a solo episode where I talk to
myself for 45 minutes.
-You have been interviewed
a great deal.
Is there something that you've
learned being sort of a subject
of an interview, that you feel
like you are stealing
to be an interviewer?
-Yeah, I would say listening.
Sometimes interviewers don't
listen, and they just kind of
stick to the, like,
"Oh, this is what we have to
hit, whatever."
And if you're listening,
you know, as somebody
in the audience, whatever,
it can be really frustrating
because you're like, "Wait.
They just said this thing,
and I want you to pick up on
that and whatever."
I feel like you do that so well.
You do listen. Howard Stern --
-I'm sorry.
I drifted off a little.
[ Laughter ]
-That was good. That was good.
-No, I will say --
-Your kids don't think
you're funny?
-I do -- Yeah, no kidding.
Howard Stern, by the way,
is a perfect example.
And I think it is true.
Whenever -- Because when I
started doing this show, I felt
like there was no background
I had to actually be good.
But the one thing is being
a good listener, and it's true.
And that's why people listen to
certain -- especially
in the podcast form, where you
can't even see anything.
You have to hear -- You kind of
have to picture it
because the conversation is
connected.
-Mm-hmm, yeah. No, it's harder
than what you do.
Okay, Seth?
-No, no, no, it's not.
I'm saying it's not because you
don't have the visual element.
-Yeah. No, no, totally.
But, yeah, it's really
enjoyable.
I love talking to people.
I think of myself as
a curious person, and I'm just
really enjoying it.
-You call it "High Low."
-Yeah.
-Can you explain the title
real quick?
-Yeah, so I have always been,
like, kind of fascinated by
the idea of their being highbrow
or sophisticated topics
and lowbrow things,
and I think that I'm someone
who, you know, people maybe
think of me in a certain way
in like an Instagram,
whatever, world,
and then I wrote
this book of essays.
So I feel like I'm high and low
a bit.
But I also just -- My favorite
way of talking about things is,
like, marrying some, you know,
political idea with
like "Housewives" or whatever.
So I don't really believe in
high and low essentially.
But it actually wasn't the first
choice for the name.
-Oh. Because "High Low"
is a very good title.
-Thank you.
-What was the first choice?
-Um, "Bitch Era."
-"Bitch Era"? Yeah.
-Mm-hmm.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, they flagged that one.
Although I named
my media Company --
-I did -- I actually --
When I was holding this up,
I noticed that, yeah, Bitch Era
did make its way.
-Yeah, yeah.
So that's my media company.
I did make my way
to getting that.
-That's good. It was available?
-It was available.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, don't laugh.
-No, it's great.
-I think it's
a high in demand name.
-Yeah, I can't believe --
I think a lot of people
are kicking themselves
right now.
They're like, "Why didn't I
think of 'Bitch Era'?"
-Yeah, it's -- I personally feel
that way.
I'm ready to make merch,
so if anybody else wants to be
in their bitch era with me --
-In 2014, I went to NBC,
I'm like,
"Bitch Era with Seth Meyers.
Think about it." And they --
[ Laughter ]
Same thing, they shut it down.
Nobody has any vision
these days.
-You're kind of
in your bitch era.
-I feel like I'm entering
my bitch era.
-I like it. I see you in
the streets in New York --
-Thank you.
I'm getting more bitchy.
-Drinking those Negronis and --
-Now, we should note, and this
is just something --
I guess -- Is that what you say
about a TikTok?
Will a TikTok "drop"
later this evening?
-Yeah, we made a TikTok.
-We did.
We made a TikTok backstage.
-You hated it so much.
You hated the process.
-I did.
-He did.
[ Laughter ]
-That's so weird because I'm
usually so good
at hiding how I feel.
I did --
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-I did hate it so much.
-You did a great job, though.
-Thank you.
I mean, I will say, I was, like,
kind of hating it, and then I
saw it, and I'm like,
"Oh, I'm really good at this."
-No, you were really good.
[ Laughter ]
It was impressive because he
hadn't heard the sound before,
but you love a Negroni.
-I love a Negroni.
-But you didn't get to sip on
the Negroni.
-Well, I couldn't sip on it
because we had --
You know, I had a show.
And I take it very seriously.
-Okay, that's great.
-I have the one Negroni at 2:00
in the afternoon,
and then I don't --
-Are you considering, like,
using TikTok more?
-Well, I mean, let's see how
it -- if it takes off.
-Is that part of your bitch era?
Is TikTok-ing?
-That's how you'll know
my bitch era has started.
If I become really active
on TikTok,
then you'll be like,
"It's happened."
-I think everyone should be
on TikTok.
It's amazing.
-You do love it, right?
-Yeah, I love it, and the whole
thing about privacy, I'm like,
"Listen, Facebook, Instagram,
they've already stolen it.
The Chinese just do better
things with it."
-Yeah.
-They have our information.
-There's nothing about any of us
that everybody doesn't already
know.
-No, and I'm telling you
the algorithm, they really --
they really know how to
entertain us.
So I'm grateful for that.
-Okay.
-I'm like, "Take my data and do
something great with it."
-Okay. Well --
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-It's really nice to hear
someone so optimistic about
the fact that all our privacy
has been stolen.
-I think it's like I've passed
the point of cynical.
-You are past, yeah.
-And now I'm just like,
"We have to just accept."
-Alright. Well, look,
acceptance, bitch era, Seth on
TikTok, it's all happening.
Thank you so much
for being here.
-Thank you so much
for having me.
-It's always a pleasure.
New episodes of
"High Low with EmRata" available
Tuesdays and Thursdays wherever
you get your podcasts.
We'll be right back with
Seth Reiss and Will Tracy.